[Music]
in the 4th century BCE a banker's son
through the city of saina p into scandal
by counterfeiting coins when the dust
finally settled the young man Diogenes
of Sinope II had been stripped of his
citizenship his money and all his
possessions at least that's how the
story goes while many of the details of
Diogenes life are shadowy the
philosophical ideas born out of his
disgrace survived today in exile
Diogenes decided that by rejecting the
opinions of others and societal measures
of success he could be truly free he
would live self-sufficiently close to
nature without materialism vanity or
conformity in practice this meant he
spent years wandering around greek
cities with nothing but a cloak staff
and knapsack outdoors year-round
forgoing technology baths and cooked
food
he didn't go about this new existence
quietly but is said to have teased
passers-by and mocked the powerful
eating urinating and even masturbating
in public the citizens called him a
a barking dog though meant as an insult
dogs were actually a good symbol for his
philosophy they're happy creatures free
from abstractions like wealth or
reputation Diogenes and his growing
number of followers became known as dog
philosophers or Cooney coy a designation
that eventually became the word cynic
these early cynics were a carefree Bunch
drawn to the freedom of a wandering life
style as Diogenes his reputation grew
others tried to challenge his commitment
Alexander the Great
offered him anything he desired but
instead of asking for material goods
Diogenes only asked Alexander to get out
of his sunshine after Diogenes death
adherence to his philosophy continued to
call themselves cynics for about 900
years until 500 CE II some Greek
philosophers like the Stoics thought
everyone should follow Diogenes as
example they also attempted to tone down
his philosophy to be more acceptable to
conventional society which of course was
fundamentally at odds with his approach
others viewed the cynics less charitably
in the Roman province of Syria in the
2nd century CE II the satirist Lucian
described the cynics of his own time as
unprincipled materialistic
self-promoting hypocrites who only
preached what Diogenes had once actually
practiced reading Lucian's texts
centuries later Renaissance and
Reformation writers called their rivals
cynics as an insult meaning people who
criticized others without having
anything worthwhile to say this usage
eventually laid the groundwork for the
modern meaning of the word cynic a
person who thinks everyone else is
acting out of pure self-interest even if
they claim a higher motive still the
philosophy of cynicism had admirers
especially among those who wished to
question the state of society the 18th
century French philosopher jean-jacques
Rousseau was called the new Diogenes
when he argued that the arts sciences
and Technology corrupt people in 1882
Friedrich Nietzsche reimagined a story
in which Diogenes went into the Athenian
marketplace with a lantern searching in
vain for a single honest person in
niches version a so-called madman rushes
into a town square
to proclaim that God is dead this was
Nietzsche's way of calling for a
revaluation of values and rejecting the
dominant Christian and platonic idea of
universal spiritual insights beyond the
physical world Nietzsche
admired Diogenes for sticking stubbornly
to the here and now more recently the
hippies of the 1960s have been compared
with Diogenes as counter cultural rebels
Diogenes ideas have been adopted and
reimagined over and over again the
original cynics might not have approved
of these fresh takes they believed that
their values of rejecting custom and
living closely with nature were the only
true values whether or not you agree
with that or with any of the later
incarnations all have one thing in
common they questioned the status quo
and that's an example we can still
follow not to blindly follow
conventional or majority views but to
think hard about what is truly valuable
thinking critically about our
institutions and way of life is more
important than ever hone your newfound
skepticism with these videos
[Music]